alan robinson of the bears may be
available unless he isn't unless he is
unless he isn't that was the ping-pong
match yesterday in the media between the
receiver who's entering the final year
of his contract with the bears
who hasn't gotten a new contract and who
wants a new contract and now
other things are unfolding now that week
one has come and gone
to try to make it happen yesterday
afternoon nfl media says
that alan robinson has removed
references to the team from his social
media reflection his frustration of the
state of talks on a new contract
no trade request as of now that was 2 42
pm eastern
less than 20 minutes later the chicago
tribune reports that alan robinson has
asked about a possible trade and then a
few hours after that
shefty says that robinson's agent says
that he and his client haven't requested
a trade however robinson is unhappy that
chicago has been unwilling to pay him
market value for wide receivers so so
basically robinson's holding
the grenade he's got the pin in one hand
and he's just getting ready to pull it
as it relates to asking for a trade
right and and uh and look maybe it's too
early in the season
to ask for a trade the trades usually
get done
later we saw last year mohamed sanu for
a second round pick emmanuel sanders for
a third round pick close to the deadline
but you know this is something that we
definitely have to monitor because he
wants to be paid the bears don't want to
do it yet
and if they're not going to do it then
trading him becomes an option chris yeah
i mean it certainly does and you know
again i'm always in favor for the player
using any avenue they need or deemed
necessary to get
you know what they feel they deserve you
know this is a tough one here
you know first off alan robinson's he's
making he's in the what the 14 million
a year range right at the wide receiver
position the other thing i would sit
there and go
i would go first off at just base value
i look at that and go
i think that's pretty fair i mean he's
in the class of the
stefan diggs t-y hilton's devonte adams
jarvis landry i would argue that those
guys are better than him so
that that would be my first thing to
just go okay wait so what's he really
commanding here
now there are some other guys that are
arguably making a little bit more than
him that you could say he's better than
yeah there might be brandon cooks who
got overpaid
you could probably make an argument for
that but here would be the other thing
too if i'm the bears where i'd go like
what wait you're asking for a new
contract you got here you've had
1 000 yard season and in the last four
years you've played
less than half the games on the schedule
he's played 31 out of 64 games
that's really hard to stand on that
ground and say
i deserve more money i'm a key part you
know first off there's injury issue
there and then
the production hasn't been so
overwhelming that i'm like oh this is
crazy you got to pay the guy go ahead
what
it's weird because he had a thousand
yard season last year
yeah when the offense was horrible right
but he still stood out
the year before that when the team was
good he was under
a thousand yards he missed three games
and you mentioned the number of games
he's missed
over a four year period one of the
problems is he toured acl week one
in 2017 and i think that makes him even
more sensitive
to getting a deal done because he knows
what can happen to a season
you're in a contract year look what
happened to marlon mack on sunday i
think that's a warning shot to anyone
out there who's trying to get a contract
the chances of you getting that injury
that that will wipe out your market
value
is there yes and he is under a
three-year 14 million dollar
contract 10.9 million in base salary
this year
and and look he's doing what he has to
do to get more he didn't hold out
he could still hold in i mean that's the
next step here
will he play until they do this deal
will he go the jalen ramsey route now
you know jaylen ramsey he
i guess what was he injured or injured i
mean everybody knew jalen ramsey wasn't
playing well
and all that right right you know well
there's a blow up now it's a different
kind of blow up now the question though
is will we see him on the field and i
think that's going to be very telling
are they going to put him on moth balls
while they figure out whether to trade
him or is it just going to be full steam
ahead
we have you under contract we're paying
you good money we expect you to show up
and play and if we trade you we trade
you
forcing him to continue to endure the
injury risk because i think the injury
risk is the reason that this has all
been
sure uh brought to a head yeah i i mean
i understand that i do and you got to
try to protect your interest in your
body that way and you when you've been
injured early in a year it scars you and
you're always going to be aware of that
whether you got injured or a friend or a
teammate you you see that
and that is in your in your mind um i
just it's out of nowhere
and here we are week one off a big win
you know you were losing to the detroit
lions i guess i just questioned the
timing of it
and you know again the player himself
is a really good player but i don't know
if i put him in the status of
okay he he he can command more money
anytime he wants type of football player
it's a little different to me there i
will say that
as far as like an alvin kamara or other
guys that we have seen you know do this
during during this lockout or training
camp
man the guys that have done it are like
integral to the team's scheme and
success
to where the the game the team is not
going to be as good unless that player
is a part of
what they're doing not only because the
player is good but because of how the
coach
uses the player within his scheme is a
perfect fit and that's also i don't
think necessarily
a thing that alan robikin robinson can
sit here and argue as far as his case on
the bears
you know i don't know if we've done this
before like pina and peanut but it there
is a a g not a c
an integral understand that right yeah
integral
integral yeah did i say coal there like
intrical
it integral crawl okay i got you all
right i think it's getting worse instead
of better we better just move on yeah
let's move
on i think i think allen robinson took
the leap of faith that something was
going to get done and then it didn't and
then week one comes and goes and in the
aftermath
you know of the the first game and
you've got covet 19 concerns you're
traveling you know you get back and
you're like
hey wait a minute this is messed up i
mean yesterday was his first day off
he has a chance to digest what's going
on he gets pissed off yeah so i
understand the timing
especially when you consider he's had a
week one season ending injury in his
past
and marlon mack had a week one season
ending injury and you throw michael
thomas on top of it too
it's another reason for guys to be
concerned if they are in the last year
of a contract
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports